[Music]
hi mystery recap here today i am going
to explain an australian science fiction
thriller film called i am mother
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the premise of the movie is set in a
dystopian future when human beings have
gone extinct before their extinction
scientists had activated a bunker as a
backup plan to repopulate the earth the
bunker is run by an ai robot called
mother she is given the responsibility
to sort through several human embryos
and raise an efficient human being who
can be the guardian of upcoming
generations
at the beginning of the movie mother
goes through 63 000 human embryos and
chooses a healthy one to raise she
places it in the gestation chamber an
advanced device that develops an embryo
into a baby in only 24 hours as she
waits for the baby to develop in the
artificial womb gunshots are heard
outside the facility she returns the
next day and brings the newborn baby
girl out of the womb the scene is
followed by a montage of mother raising
the child she watches daughter walking
for the first time nurtures her when she
cries and loves her dearly in their free
time daughter and mother make origami
together mother even teaches her to
dance when daughter grows up to an
appropriate age mother introduces her to
the other embryos and tells her about
her purpose in the world a few more
years later daughter turns into a
teenager she often watches videos of
humans on her tablet although she is one
of them she is fascinated by their
nature
one day when a technical problem arises
in mother's hand she easily fixes it
this makes mother realize that she has
done a good job raising daughter every
day for an hour mother teaches daughter
about morals and ethics she gives her
hypothetical questions to test her
morality her primary aim is to
familiarize daughter with the concept of
humanity soon she will have to attend a
final test that will show the efficiency
of mother's upbringing one night
daughter has a hard time falling asleep
so she watches videos of humans on her
tablet suddenly the power cuts off she
goes outside looking for mother and
finds that she is also out of power she
finds a broken cable to be the cause of
the power loss as she brainstorms what
might have caused it she hears a mouse
squeaking daughter has never seen a live
animal before she excitedly sets a mouse
trap and fixes the cable while waiting
for the power to come back she catches
the mouse and inspects it in fascination
after charging up mother finds her with
the animal and takes it away the mouse's
presence means a rupture in the airlock
system of the bunker which worries her
she claims that the air outside the
bunker is highly toxic which can kill
humans instantly
mother probably should have dropped this
bomb earlier
following that she takes measures to
ensure the air inside has not been
contaminated since the mouse is also a
potential carrier of the contamination
she incinerates it against daughter's
protests a few days later they celebrate
daughter's birthday at dinner a curious
daughter asks mother if humans can
somehow survive outside the bunker the
mouse's existence has made her question
mother's teachings mother simply replies
that she knows there are no humans
outside and since she has never been
wrong she declares it as a fact later
that day daughter hears a noise coming
from the airlock of the facility she
goes near to check but doesn't see
anything from the first door when the
noise gets louder she puts on a hazmat
suit and opens the door as she moves
closer to the second one she hears a
human female yelling for help claiming
that she has been shot by a droid
daughter quickly gets a hazmat suit for
the woman to help her she closes the
first hatch to maintain a safe distance
then opens the entrance letting her in
when the door opens mother is alerted
the woman begs her to not tell mother
about her arrival daughter is skeptical
because she has never hidden anything
from mother mother arrives but doesn't
see the injured woman as she stays
hidden in the airlock when inquired as
to what happened daughter claims that
she accidentally opened the entrance as
a punishment for her mistake she is
asked to take the final test right then
mother brings her to a classroom and
gives her the tablet with the questions
after she leaves daughter abandons the
test and goes to see the woman she finds
her unconscious because of her injury
she goes through her belongings just to
be safe and finds a gun she then wakes
the woman up and offers her water as the
woman opens her mask to drink it
daughter protests against the
contamination it is then revealed to her
that there is no contamination in the
outside world and mother has been lying
to her this entire time
daughter hides the woman in a part of
the bunker before mother can see them
she then goes to collect the required
medicines from the infirmary in the
meantime mother finds the poison mask in
the airlock the woman sees mother
throwing her poison mask in the
incinerator frightened she checks for
the gun in her bag but doesn't find it
when daughter returns the woman sneaks
up on her and asks her about the gun she
refers to mother as a droid and wants
the gun to protect herself from her
mother is surprised when she reaches the
classroom and finds daughter missing she
sees the woman holding daughter and
sprints towards them the woman manages
to shoot her once but the bullet doesn't
do any harm she grabs the woman and
overpowers her easily daughter tries
stopping her claiming that the only
reason the woman is here is because she
needs their help mother understands the
problem and takes the injured woman to
the infirmary however she doesn't allow
daughter to come in with her following
that mother interrogates the woman while
dressing her wounds but doesn't get any
answers after she is done she tells
daughter that she lied to her about the
contamination to keep her safe from the
dangers of the outside world daughter
doesn't know what to think of the
revelation later that day daughter goes
through the woman's belongings again and
finds a book with several sketches of
people she goes to the woman and
inquires about it but the woman doesn't
say anything suspecting that mother has
sent her to question her when daughter
defends her mother the woman tells her
that droids have done horrible things to
humans later daughter apologizes to
mother for letting the woman in mother
lovingly makes her understand the
consequences and forgives her the
woman's health gets worse but she
doesn't trust mother to perform surgery
on her hence daughter takes the
initiative and takes the bullet out
successfully when the woman wakes up
from the surgery daughter gives her some
food which she devours the two talk as
mother watches them from afar the
following day the woman tells her that
the sketches in the book are her family
members she asks daughter to keep
everything she is about to say a secret
from mother she then tells her about the
survivor's camp in the mines that she
was brought up in daughter insists that
the facility has enough resources to
help the people from the camp so they
should bring them here however the woman
instead wants daughter to join them in
the camp
later mother informs daughter that the
bullet she found from inside the woman
was identical to the one from her gun so
she suspects her own kind had shot her
daughter then finally takes the test and
passes with flying colors as a gift
mother lets her pick any embryo to raise
next the two patiently wait for the
infant to be born later the woman asks
daughter to check the bullets herself
and confirm who shot her humans or the
droids she does as said and finds out
that the bullets are completely
different meaning that mother is lying
to her yet again
while she is at it she also finds
documents labeled for embryo number two
she goes through the files and realizes
that she is not the first baby produced
in the facility some of the others are
labeled failed so she then checks the
incinerator to find the remains of a
human jaw she also discovers a document
that says the subject was aborted
shocked that her mother killed the other
babies she no longer trusts her she runs
to the woman and tells her about her
findings daughter then makes up her mind
to run to the camp with the woman
however she wants her brother to be born
first so she can take him as well the
following day daughter collects supplies
for their escape but mother catches her
in the act mother fools her by acting
like she doesn't know about her plan and
takes her to the kitchen she eventually
locks her there and goes to the woman to
ask her about her true motive meanwhile
daughter manages to break the glass door
by spraying a chemical on it the woman
and mother get into a fight but mother
gets distracted when daughter sets off
the fire alarm the woman then finds
daughter and convinces her to run away
without her brother when mother tries to
stop them the woman takes daughter
hostage and demands that mother open the
door for them mother obliges as she
doesn't want daughter to get hurt the
two finally escape and run outside
however the barren land and the bizarre
reality of the outside world angers
daughter and she attacks the woman the
woman insists they need to find cover as
soon as possible and the two start to
run again they are followed by human
killing droids and narrowly escape to
their destination the woman informs
daughter that the droids harvested corn
six months ago before that humans could
hardly breathe they reach a beach with
massive cargo containers at first
daughter is mesmerized by the beauty of
the sea but then she realizes the camp
the woman was talking about is the cargo
containers the woman finally comes clean
and says that the people at the camp
started getting crazy because of the
lack of food so she had fled from there
years ago the daughter is shocked and
regrets coming with her without thinking
much about it she flees back to the
facility again
however at the entrance she encounters
several droid guards who hold her at
gunpoint when she mentions mother they
let her go inside without further
questioning mother is glad she is safe
and invites her to come closer to look
at her brother when she calms down
mother finally explains to her the true
purpose of her existence it turns out
that before daughter she raised several
humans and let them free into the
outside world but she failed to consider
that they might turn evil and fight
amongst themselves when her children
started to threaten the second
extinction of humanity she took measures
to stop them and appointed the droids
starting then she decided to raise
humans who are ethical like daughter as
the two look at the newborn lovingly
daughter asks her about the human
remains she had found before mother can
explain herself she holds the baby and
tries to get away from the facility by
trapping mother the droids outside are
notified and start cutting through the
entrance door daughter points a gun at
mother asking her to tell the other
droids to retreat mother explains that
she and other droids share the same
vision and consciousness she then tells
daughter that she can either leave the
facility without her brother or help her
raise him
however daughter insists that mother has
already done her task by raising her she
wants a chance to show her capabilities
to her by raising the child on her own
suddenly the droids stop cutting through
the entrance mother asks daughter to
disable her as she has fulfilled her
purpose daughter shoots at her cpu
finally killing her she then takes on
the responsibility to save humanity from
extinction
we then see the woman meet a droid who
looks just like mother it tells the
woman that she has fulfilled her purpose
suggesting that she is also one of the
mother's children who was presumably
appointed to help her test daughter's
potential in the end daughter is seen
singing to her baby brother and checking
on the other embryos subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching